[Music]
snow means something different to
everyone
snoke takes all the complicated details
and simplifies the landscape to the
possibilities of a naturally occurring
sculpture
for snow globe artist walter martin and
paloma munoz
snow is what draws you into their
surreal world
there's like a paradise feeling where
man and beast live in peace and work
together to do the laundry
here they work out ambitions and
exercise anxiety teetering is a sense of
teetering and of tenuous balance
the globes freeze miniature landscapes
in wintry wonder
twisted logic
and macabre humor
it's like our own little form of poetry
inspired by nature in the elements we
feel a lot of angst and dread
sometimes in the winter and
it goes into the glove
the couple puts a modern twist on an
age-old craft
transforming knickknacks into custom
works of art
[Music]
so imagine a world full of stories
and the camera goes in and just picks up
this little fragment in time and a
little moment
and that's what the globes are they are
samples of the larger world
but becomes alive
when you shake it
working together for us is one
experiment maybe like a marriage but
it's a more complex marriage because
we're trying to create
art together we've been doing the snow
globes now for almost 15 years
we started in 2001 that was when we made
the first one
and we had no idea we were going to be
making snow globes 15 years later
[Music]
everything starts with a small canvas
that is the space that you have to fill
in the globe
and then you start adding figures
and you continue to explore the
landscape and relationship to those
figures
i think i was fascinated with the way
that snow kind of takes all the
complicated details and simplifies the
landscape
the unification of the landscape
it tends to be a great equalizer
and when there's something outside of
that world that's interjected into it
like a human with a colorful wardrobe or
an animal or a small house or anything
that's not of that world becomes a focus
it is a frozen world
we live at the edge of a small town
and on the other side of our house is
northeastern american forest
it's complete wilderness
and we walk it every day
and we love it
depending on the day the time of year
and the time of day and weather the
forest can offer a totally different
face it's like we have one foot in the
wilderness and one foot on civilization
we can bring those worlds together
through our work
[Music]
we say a lot of silly things throughout
the day it leads us into the work
i'm from norfolk virginia which is a
flat coastal city in the mid-atlantic
region not known for its snowstorms
so i fantasized about escaping to a
place where there was snow for me the
challenge is always
how to make something that is relevant
that contributes something to the
conversation
of what art is and what
being a human being in this moment in
time is like
a successful snow globe would be
absurdist humor combined with a real
human condition
i think people find their gloves very
interesting they love them they absorb
you and they allow the viewer to be
immersed
even for just a few seconds in a
completely different world
[Music]
you